most black children were being raised in
two parent families in 1960.
30 years after the liberal welfare state
the great majority of black children
were being raised by single parents yeah
what what what's the what how does that
by the way we should note
that and okay because before there was a
consequence
and this is in society if you take away
the consequences to every anything more
people do it before if you were a single
mom you damn near were maybe homeless
okay so so people were a lot more scared
to get pregnant
you know it's crazy there were less
single moms then and it was easier to
get pregnant there was birth control no
birth control yeah so it's like easier
for us to avoid pregnancy yeah and there
was less of them men
how what do you think that there was
less because
a lot of the men were
off at war i mean was there war my
history is horrible i don't know
do you think that it was less because
the men were
essentially doing more or weren't at
home as
much
do you think that's
why do you think
no i think i think again it's you they
took away the consequence of being a
single mom if you were a single mom
before you were [ __ ] out of luck
and now and now the government yeah they
give you money
so
so before it was you you'd be afraid of
being homeless now there's no fear
because they take away the consequence
oh this video's gonna make my head
explode
and the thing with money showing who you
are like if if you got rich tomorrow
like i i think you'd probably
live a little like you'd probably spend
a little bit more
but are you
i'm
if i got rich tomorrow i would act like
i have no money still no i'd probably be
able to like go out to eat a little bit
more splurge a little bit treat myself
but
i would
essentially for me i think i would act i
would act
the same and it wouldn't be like oh i'm
wearing the designer stuff like no i
have clothes i'm still going to keep
them but like the things that i want
that i know like
if i got them now i would hurt in
another area i would be able to be like
okay i can get that i can get that i can
get that i get that and essentially
make things
better for
any situation that i wanted to and i
would be able to help out my
my family but i wouldn't
yeah because that's who you are and it's
the same thing with me like i'm not
going to buy designer clothes
but i would buy a second soundboard send
money
if you're in premiere
if you're in premiere send money please
please go to the uh pre-game show super
chats please
pat moynihan patrick moynihan publishes
the moynihan report in 1965
and he's alarmed because the
illegitimacy rate among black families
is 25 then
now among whites it's over a third
hispanics it's over half and among
african americans it's over 70 percent
what's going on there
well this is again this too you find the
same thing in britain you find it in uh
france and norway you find it in the
western world
uh in fact uh there's a solution of the
family structure oh yeah there are any
number of western nations
where forty percent of the children
are raised with with only one parent
right uh at the extremes
compared to
asian countries
at the extremes of iceland it's two out
of three uh children born are raised in
a single single-parent home uh in south
korea it's one out of 66.
wow
wow
and so what
that's the welfare state what yes it is
are you you're paying you you're
creating a situation where the if the uh
first of all
well you're you're creating a situation
where if the man stays there the the
government will not give them give the
woman welfare
uh and if he leaves he it will and so
they're pa they're paying when you pay
people not to get married more people
don't get married right
it's so simple
but yet it's so like
because you're not really taught this
you're not at all you just think oh the
the idea that i had about welfare is
that
if you if you're struggling or if you
can't afford something that's when you
get on welfare and that's it and a funny
thing
there's a movie called kingdom come and
there's a um
a scene where um
loretta divine she's the actress
and her son i cannot remember his name
but it was the um
the oldest son in uh
family matters have you seen family
matters it doesn't matter
and so
she
she's a churchgoing woman and so she was
he was telling her like yeah i'm gonna
find me a church-going girl settle down
have a couple kids and then we're gonna
get a welfare and so that's just that's
something that keeps popping into my
head whenever they say welfare and to un
to know like
what it
it is it's like
welfare it's trash this is literally the
one of the worst things
that could have been implemented into
the government
right she's going to become a
conservative
and i understand why they don't teach it
in school because if they taught it in
school then it wouldn't be a thing
anymore more and more people would not
more people wouldn't be single mom more
and more people wouldn't do the things
that
causes them to depend on the government
they're paying you to make poor
decisions
and the people and the people that make
good decisions pay for like my dad my
dad okay my dad was
was like poor like he grew up one of 13
kids wow he he south side of chicago
well half his childhood he spent in like
rural
wisconsin and half in the south they'd
move every four years i don't know why
wow my grandpa was a fire my grandpa was
a fireman's that's not my grandma didn't
work that wasn't a crazy good salary
right for 13 kids they should yeah yeah
we had 13 kids yeah firefighter yeah
okay so it wasn't like he grew up rich
my dad is a workaholic he my dad has
made every good just like better
decisions that i've even made like never
drank never done drugs
never i think he said he smoked a
cigarette once in third grade and he
didn't like it that was it
he he he married the girl he started
dating in his early twenties
had
seven kids by her grew a milk
multi-million dollar like did this why
does he have to pay
for someone else's poor decisions he
just chooses because there are people
that just choose not to work
and i'm not against no safety net like i
think there's you know mentally disabled
people yeah people with a very low iq
that just can't function in society you
have to think of them but like
like that's that's
because i think naturally i lean more
left because i'm a very empathetic
person and i really i enjoy helping
people so my personality is more left
but when my dad explains this to me i'm
like yeah why should you have to pay for
them
yeah as you understand you understand
both
both sides
of it and
it's
my like literally my mind is everywhere
right now with this information and
i
i literally want to be thinking about
this
all day
and i'm going to sit down and be like
what bro
where
where could
society be
and just like thinking about like the
black community like what
like i i think there is someone i have a
theory that there is someone racist like
behind the scenes that i knew yeah
no no no no like
no no like like i don't know who it was
but because they implement this and it
disproportionately affects the black
community and then on top of that
abortion yeah like that the black
population would be double today if it
weren't for abortion like that is a
disproportionately
like that affects that community and so
like how crazy is that there would be
double of everybody and so on top of
that yeah like and and the person who
started planned parenthood she believed
in like keeping the bloodline pure like
she was a eugenic like i don't i forget
the word for it but like where where you
believe in like keeping like i don't
know pure blood like whatever
if i didn't know what he said no i don't
know
i think it's eugenic like she just
basically believed in basically breeding
and she was like and so they literally
marketed planned parenthood to black
communities
and and they basically succeeded because
the black community would be double
today and like you never hear about this
like i
imagine if nike was founded this way
imagine
imagine if nike had some but but for
whatever reason planned parenthood gets
a pass why
why
oh and it's the same people they say
they're for women's rights
okay so how does how does an abortion
help me
does that make me in a better mental
state but there's a lot of there's a lot
of like
physical stuff that happens when you
get an abortion and it could and mental
and it encourages you to make what bad
decisions it encourages women to sleep
around like they're saying oh it's okay
sleep around as much as you want there's
no consequences for it which is a lie
that's a lie because we release a
hormone men don't when we have sex so we
get attached and they don't
so do that as much as you want even and
get pregnant and there's still no
consequence because you can
get an abortion it's just like
they take away personal responsibility
oh
oh my
jesus
right okay so so what would have
happened
if lyndon johnson instead of becoming a
liberal
had remained a crusty tough skeptical
texas texas conservative yes which is
certainly the way he started his career
if he if lyndon johnson had embraced the
constrained
vision
instead of instituting the war on
poverty and the great society and so
forth what would the country look like
today a lot better you would not have
the same rates of crime and so on
because you see you can't have a welfare
state in a democratic country unless you
first have a welfare state vision and
when you buy all the assumptions that
vision then you're buying a lot of
trouble one of the one of the episodes i
think epitomized it was in france in
this case uh that there were tax knife
attacks by various people from north
africa against chinese people in uh in
some suburbs of paris
and one of the
things that the attacker said you know
that uh why are you attacking the
chinese and it wasn't because anything
the chinese had done to them said they
have nice clothes and big cars that's
not fair
i mean that's you know
egalitarianism as a philosophy is one
thing but the actual consequences of it
are mean things like resenting other
people's good fortune right
so i wonder
what was it
that this person that implemented this
law what was it about the
black community that they did not like
that they were like
if we do this
this is going to
change the whole trajectory of the whole
community
and negatively affect them but
positively benefit us
i don't know
i don't i couldn't tell you
oh
but you see what he said there with the
hating you hear this narrative well
they'll be like eat the wretch
like let's tax the re like you know what
i'm saying there's more money it's like
a jealousy thing
yeah and and here's the thing here's the
thing if
let's say what if what if amazon jeff
bezos said you know what screw all you
people
i'm done amazon poof gone
and instead of like it would it would be
terrible and we're not even thankful to
these people it's like we hate them why
they're providing a service we all enjoy
literally everybody bro i could not live
without amazon everybody would have went
crazy during the pandemic if they didn't
have amazon
but we hate them even though we
benefited
and you'll see it the more you're gonna
you're gonna see it the more successful
you get people that aren't no no people
that aren't successful are going to be
jealous of you and feel like they're
entitled to
wow
yeah like it it happens all the like all
the time because my parents i swear to
god the nicest kindest most giving
people i know i like i love my parents
but you also grow up seeing people
really take advantage of that and become
entitled wow like we had people we were
funding we were funding their life
my dad would give them like a salary per
year not that they didn't even work like
a relative right
they
they i'm not gonna say what they did but
they did something like
very backstabbing to my dad they were
family yeah it was the hand that hand
that fed him yeah
because we remember 1-13 there's a lot
of yeah yeah but yeah it's just like
like resentment in comparison it's the
thief of joy
and if if this stuff was
i'm just like thinking about if this
stuff was actually like
taught to people at a young age they
would be able to
think differently and know that okay
this was implemented for
a negative effect i'm not going to go
down the same route that
they want me to i'm going to strive to
do better but we're not taught that as
i'll tell you why oh they're okay
because you can't see this because the
schools are in like cahoots with the
government they're the government yeah
so the problem is that they're not going
to teach it to you in schools because
that would require holding schools
accountable
and it's like like it used to be that
people could pick where to send their
kids to school and this this
disproportionately affected the black
community too because if you were low
income you could still send your kid to
a good school you wouldn't you weren't
stuck by that zip code but now where
you're born you're forced to go to a
[ __ ] school no matter how bad the
teachers are and if you
did you hear the story about the mom
that
sent her child and she i don't i can't
remember she went to jail but she
initially got in trouble for it yeah and
it's like
how do you
want better for your child
but essentially get in trouble for it
but it's like you're not putting anybody
in harm's way you're not doing you're
just sending them to a better school to
have a better life oh my god and this is
what this is what blows my mind so in
chicago okay they get 13 000. last i
checked around 12 13 000 per kid so
every kid that goes to a school the
government gives you the 12 13k to the
to the city of chicago okay chicago has
terrible schools you know as better test
scores my school you know what the
tuition is in my school eight thousand
dollars per kid you know the difference
between us and the public schools the
public schools
had really nice facilities they had a
beautiful gym all this [ __ ] okay
my school didn't have any of that we
didn't have air conditioning but they
invested in what teachers oh wow oh
because like a nice gym is going to make
you more educated
so so it's like the the and
but the problem with teaching positions
is it's like it's there's no incentive
there's no
if you teach for 10 years you're on
tenure they can't fire you yeah and then
okay and then you're going to see this
differently too because the unions
like teachers unions are basically to
protect teachers from getting fired but
some of them should get fired yeah and
so they'll march the streets and say oh
we're fighting for teachers you're not
fighting for teachers if you're a good
teacher you're not going to be let go
yeah exactly so but it's really hard to
fire teachers especially if they've been
there after a certain time and no matter
how no matter how
bad they are
if they hit a certain mark like tenure
they get to stay and they get to
continually
teach
the way they are teaching and i've had
teachers that have been like why why are
you a teacher
why are you here you hate your life when
you're here you don't want to you don't
want to
teach us anything that's actually going
to help us why are you here and and you
know what you know what would help but
they used to do charter schools so you
could say okay the 13k that the
government gives the schools for my kid
i want it to go to that school
and then do you know who would do you
know who would you would see if they did
that you would see business people jump
in
because they're like oh [ __ ] i can make
13 000 as a kid
i'm gonna figure out a way to educate
them in the best way possible so i can
make money like wanting to make money
isn't a bad thing if you're providing a
service that everybody needs but the
problem is the government strong arms
these parents descending like it's not
fair and i say this like if there's one
policy i could like fight for it would
be education equality because that's
like you shouldn't just because you're
born poor you shouldn't be stuck having
a [ __ ] education like i got a good
education because my parents could
afford it that's not fair
like
and so it's like the same thing they
take away the consequence for the school
because no matter how bad of a job they
do
the government still
pays them and the consequence used to be
i'm pulling my kid yeah but now they're
send you to jail
and then the teachers will say oh
let's fight for more pay but it's not a
it's about
you
and there was there's a school in new
york that did it because so there are
charter schools a little bit right
but
there aren't enough so it's by it's by
lottery basically so it's like it's like
at random you can apply to possibly but
you have to be chosen
and there was a school in new york that
did it they paid all their teachers six
figures
you had people that like weren't even
teachers applying they were just like
really good at music really good because
i think there's so many people that like
i would teach if there was more money in
it
i would and there was some incentive
like where it wasn't just
like if i was better at teaching i would
get more money yeah but
like i would do a youtube course i
totally like there's a ton of kids i
want to do oh yeah yeah sure and
like and i would be good at it too i'd
be really good at but i would never do
it because i don't want to make 45k a
year for like for what no and not and
live off of 10 like it's just not but
the
and at that school they literally
recorded lectures and then after school
they would tell them okay this you say
it this way that's wrong you need to
explain it in that way and like it was
like and like teachers would quit
because it was so stressful but these
kids improved so like it was all
low-income kids that improv like had a
yeah
but why isn't
like stuff like that
why isn't that because the way they
market it they market it they say oh
you're not fighting for teachers like
they you like did you you remember when
the i don't know if you heard of this
but in chicago there's a really big
teachers like riot and like they're on
strike
which is so selfish
like it's not about you it's about the
kids yes exactly like
yes teachers
if you if you
believe if you're
i won't even say that but
essentially it's not
it's not about you if you're
it's about the the kids in the grand
scheme of things and
if you're not
like i said my brain is everywhere right
i work for youtube i can't be on strike
if i'm about strike from youtube i just
stopped getting paid yeah exactly
and and like negotiate with your
employer like figure or or go get a
better like go negotiate with another
school but you're making the kids pay
for this yeah
i never understood a stripe
i'm not about to go on strike and miss
money like
yes i may be it may be low it may not be
where i want it to be but if i'm gonna
go talk to somebody take up take a day
off and not get paid just to walk around
no
no and then go back to work and nothing
changed yeah and i missed a day of work
yeah no i want to i'm telling you once
you see it you can't unsee it
all right so
one response to the gap
again i returned to this gap between
african-americans and other americans
affirmative action yes which brings us
back to your alma mater harvard
accordingly i know i'll never live it
down you'll never live it down yes
you once told me that the principal
benefit of a harvard degree was never
again having to be impressed by anybody
who had harvard degrees
absolutely
so
these are figures that were published in
the harvard crimson the student
newspaper in the harvard class of 2019
these are the kids who will be
graduating next june the average s.a.t
score for black students was 21.49
by the way these are all good scores but
for black students 2149 white students
22 18
asian students
2300.
well now that must be reasonable because
it's taking place at harvard the seat
of reason
well well that wasn't quite how i
described it when i was there
affirmative action is that is that
we ought not to be doing this
you know there are various uh
laws and policies that benefit one group
at the expense of another
but i think affirmative action has the
distinction of being one that harms
everybody though in different ways
and so you you there
there's a lot of evidence
that there are black kids who have all
the qualifications to be successes in
college who nevertheless are failures
because they are systematically
mismatched with institutions whose
standards they don't meet even though
they may meet the standards of 80 or 90
of the colleges in america
i remember first aware of this when i
was teaching at cornell
why isn't
i wish that was something that was
taught
in school like
these are
your qualifications yes you may want to
go to this ivy league school but you'll
be more successful if you go to these
schools
because it shouldn't be taught they
should be denied
that's true like you shouldn't be
accepted to a school you're not
qualified for
that's true but then it goes back to
what we talked about last time quota
and
it hurts and and it hurts the smartest
kids too
because that's as he said someone that
goes to harvard even you know that you
have to have some like they might but
they're going to think they're dumb
and they're not they're smarter than 80
to 90 percent of people yeah
it's
there's just so much that
could
possibly positively affect
a nation but it's like
why why is it like why isn't it
happening
but i know that if it happens
then
people are going to
become more as independent or like be
able to think for themselves and not
have to
depend depend on the government or
depend on this depend on that and it's
going to be less and less of
like a
a hole that
these overarching things have on people
and people are going to be more free to
be a human
and
it's the media i'm telling you and and
the crazy thing is it's the same thing
that's right i hate people that are act
like they're doing the right thing so
the people they're saying oh well i'm
fighting i'm fighting for black people
i'm letting them into harvard i'm we
need
yeah if it's not like yes you could be
letting them in but
if it's not a successful situation for
them how are you how are you helping
them yes on their resume may say harvard
and they may
but if they don't graduate there's
nothing on the resume yeah and they
switch their major like he he might talk
about this in a second because i've read
a couple of his books and and one of his
books
he said like it would i can't remember
but it was a high percentage would
switch their majors from like
engineering to to an art
to or something easier to communicate
graduate yeah
yeah do you realize how many more people
would actually
if
if we
if they were
if they went to the schools that they
were more successful at do you realize
how many more people would use their
majors pick a major that they enjoyed
and that they were successful in and
then afterwards be able to use it
instead of just picking an easy major
just just to graduate and then oh my
gosh this is another layer okay another
layer is that the reason there's so much
college debt is because they took away
the consequence like usually
people should be denied for loans that
can't afford loans
but that's that's how it worked before
they subsidized education in the 1960s
or 70 i don't remember what year but
late late night
but whenever whenever that happened what
they did was say you were going to give
oh we want more poor people to go to
college right so so let's give all of
them loans anyone can get a loan
regardless and instead of being denied
those loans they were given loans and
now you see people paying off college
debt into their 50s like that's that's
insane and then it hurts the people
later so that's another problem as to
why you see so many people going to
colleges they can't afford and getting
degrees that don't make any money and it
hurts you know who it hurts the most too
poor kids because like at least me even
even upper like middle class even even
the kids that like my parents could
afford my college but the kids i grew up
around they knew to get a degree in
engineering math like my my dad
no you can't get a like i
i'm doing communications right but i
have an economics degree because he was
like i'm not paying for a degree that
doesn't have an roi
oh wow
so and you know it helps me a little bit
on the channel still probably more than
a communications degree honestly but
like if you don't have that guidance and
you're 18 sure i'll sign up for college
not everyone is college that they don't
know any better
how are you supposed to know
and now they're saying oh forgive all
college debt but now what about the
people that did the right thing and paid
it off
yeah
do they get reimbursed for that do you
get their money back
no
that's crazy what i was just thinking
about like if
if we were taught that go to a school
that you can or if they didn't
ever implement the law like we're going
to give you
any type of loans
and
you went to the school you could afford
went to the school you were most
successful in
in
in the black community
would there be so many
kids that are
in sports and they think that that
that's their way out and if they don't
play a sport they can't get out would
that would they resort to that or would
they resort to
i this is a college i can afford this is
a college i know i'm going to be
successful in
and
i'm able to play a sport with academics
come before the athletics
you would think you would think if they
were taught the numbers because your
chance of going to the league is slim
yeah
my parents always told me like even now
i have a chance i could play pro if i
want in um probably germany or something
my dad tells me it's not a career that's
not your future
you can do it if you want but it's not
your future because there's so there's
so many
that think i'm going to the league i'm
going to the inside like you may be
great great for your high school great
for your college but
it's it's so hard and there's so like
it's such a slim little area to where
that you actually are able to go
to
play in
the league and then if you don't it's
like
devastating you went to college with
this
major that you didn't really care about
but you needed a major because you
needed to play basketball but now like
what what do you have to fall back on oh
and you know what they don't push either
plumbers electricians i'm talking about
that with my mom traits like trade work
it's like
she when she was going to school she was
that was something that was implemented
in school like trade work being being a
plumber being an electrician hardware
and um
welding like those are
well-paid jobs but they're not
looked at as well painted out because oh
it's a plumber like a trash a trash man
he made babies
if i would have known that i would be
out there driving that truck
go to the back of the truck i'd be out
there i'd be a trash woman right now if
i probably know nothing like they make
money or anyone like that it's trash wow
and
it's like
oh
okay all right
and i found that half the black students
at cornell were on some kind of academic
probation and so i went over to the
administration building look up the sats
of these students the average black
student at cornell at that time scored
at the 75th percentile
which is pretty darn good yes
and so that means that that in most
colleges in this country they would have
no trouble and many of them would be on
the dean's list
but at cornell the average liberal arts
student at that time was in the 99th
percentile
and and when you when you when you're
teaching students like that uh you teach
at a pace
that most people
of any race cannot keep up with and i i
was it was always complained that i was
assigning all kinds of uh reading
but heck i'm teaching kids who are in
the top one percent they can they they
can keep up with it with the reading
that i'm assigning
uh so cornell was taking very talented
black kids and spending four years
teaching them to feel inadequate yes
six and succeed
oh this is
this is not a good video to watch right
now while it's this time of the month
because it's emotional to oh
yeah just like where could those like
those kids that he was talking about
that were on academic probation where
could they have been if they were placed
in a situation for them to succeed i'm
thinking about just my friends my family
that if they were put
in a
a situation to succeed where would they
be right now right that's why i think
quotas are racist it's white people
saying oh black people can't do it
themselves that's racist oh that's like
that's it's yes it's so racist saying
that you need our hope yeah you need our
help
like the audacity of these people the
audacity but we never look at it like
that it's the same thing like honestly
am i am i having reparations same thing
you need art we need to say like
like you're not you're not competent
enough to do it yourself you can't you
can't get out of the situation
you're in
so you need you need our help you need
reparation that reparation would be nice
it's like
extra money but like you need like you
need you need the government you need us
our help you need the quotas you need to
sat in the third to be able to get out
the situation it's like that is
it may not be taught to us like right in
our face but subconsciously that is
something that's implemented in the in
just society and it's taught us
subconsciously to where
we don't realize we're depending on this
that and the third to be able to get our
situations like we don't no you can't oh
no
like
oh
okay we're just gonna keep going
a couple quotations this is these are
both from the last affirmative action
case to reach the supreme court last big
affirmative action case to reach the
supreme court 2003 uh grudder versus
bollinger
here's the majority opinion which was
written by justice sandra day o'connor
quote
the court expects that 25 years from now
the use of racial preferences will no
longer be necessary this upholding the
use of in a decision 5-4 decision
upholding the use of racial preferences
now that's quotation 1 here's quotation
2 justice thomas justice clarence thomas
in a dissent quote
i believe that blacks can achieve in
every avenue of american life
without the meddling of university
administrators
the court holds that racial
discrimination and admission should be
given another 25 years
while i agree that in 25 years these
practices will be illegal
they are illegal now
[Laughter]
close quote
so
here's
what do you do with the argument that
justice o'connor writing that majority
opinion
there's something of the constrained
vision there look we have these all
universities across the country are
using these racial
preferences to as the basis of admission
the best we can hope to do is tell them
they ought not to be doing it that they
should be developing other standards and
give them a give them a clock
is
that a reasonable thing to do
no but it's a universal thing to do
i wrote a book uh about affirmative
action it was called affirmative action
around the world and i made a couple of
international trips at the expense of
the hoover institution
around the world to check out
affirmative action this is one of the
one of the most common arguments that is
absolutely fallacious time and time
again the argument that
like so much in the unconstrained vision
it assumes that we have a power that we
do not have
cannot have and never had to have had
in england there was a man named skarman
who was saying for the now we must do
this in order to order and in many
countries these pr these programs were
set up with an actual cut-off date
so it was set up with in malaysia with a
cut-off date i think of around
1990 and in pakistan it was like it was
supposed to go for 10 years none of
those
cut off dates has meant
a thing these programs not only continue
they increase they spread
so the idea that you can control for the
future
because of these wonderful sounding
words
i can't think of a country in the world
where that's ever happened
in the case of pakistan they did have an
absolute
actual cut-off date
and because the people in east pakistan
were for whatever historical reason
way behind the people in west pakistan
and so there's these preferences with
east pakistanis
now before time for this thing to expire
the east pakistanis uh see seed from
pakistan and formed a new nation of
bangladesh right and the preferences
continued right on because there were
other groups that had been added to it
and so once you get the constituency you
can't say no to them
i see it it is an argument that that
has never worked out anywhere that i've
been able to to check all right so
tom sol says no to the welfare state no
to affirmative action
what is to be done and now you were kind
enough to share with me
uh the galleys of your forthcoming
edition of discrimination and
disparities let me give you a few
quotations from
some of the the new chapter in that book
quote
the poverty rate among black
married couples has been less than 10
every year since 1994. as far back as
1969
young black males whose homes included
newspapers magazines and library cards
had similar incomes to those of their
white counterparts
academic outcomes show a pattern of
disparities similar to the pattern of
disparities
in the amount of time devoted to school
work
apparently
lifestyle choices have
consequences yes close quote
so this is the constrained vision once
again
welfare state that's government we don't
rely on that
affirmative action government we don't
rely on that
we rely on hard work
we rely on the institution of marriage
is that's correct yes in other words
these things i don't think it's the
marriage as such the library cards as
such
it's that there are lifestyle choices
that have been made and and the
comparison i made was between if you
look at the poverty rate among blacks uh
uh it was a 22
and among whites was 11
but among black married couples it was
7.5 right so it's not so they not only
do better than blacks as a whole they do
better than whites as a whole
and so it's it's so it's lifestyle
choices similarly with with the results
and the some of these are more
successful charter schools
but then you implement the welfare
system and that destroys it
i think there's a stat that say that
says
i'm getting the number partially wrong
but i want to say 18
of men in the black community father 80
percent of the kids
and um
half of half of like 45 or 50
of black guys are single child listen in
the middle class
and yet on the media we see
them painted as like entertainers as
players but literally it's it's a very
small percentage that actually is oh
oh my goodness
oh
she's red pilling on camera oh my
goodness my brain is doing
somersaults right now with
yeah
yeah we're just going to keep doing some
research
you have these kids not only meeting but
exceeding the national standards in
places like harlem and beverage divers
in the south bronx
and these are not kids who are
skimming the crown cream they're kids
chosen by lottery
they don't even test them for ability
they don't even look at their academic
records they take them into the schools
and and they and they have the charter
system i was telling you about yeah
that's what he's talking about so that's
what he said they don't test you it's by
lottery
okay remember when i was saying the
charter yeah okay i'd work and they make
it clear at the outset and they don't
tolerate a lot of nonsensical behavior
uh and and these kids are doing
incredibly so
come here
again i think back to the moynihan well
no i think so the moynihan report in 65
and he was very alarmed by uh
the illegitimacy rate of 25 among
african-americans by the way in fairness
to the late moynihan we should point out
one reason he was alarmed by this was
his own his own father had walked out on
the family when he was 10 years old he
experienced what it meant yes to be to
kids to have one parent okay and now
it's all gotten dramatically worse for
whites and hispanics and for everybody
and then i think
back beyond that to your experience of
harlem
you drop out of high school and do what
go on welfare start cashing no
you went to work
and you spent some of that money to buy
some inexpensive encyclopedias yeah
and the
harlem was
so
but i feel this uh council it's almost a
council of despair
in that that world just seems so utterly
vanished
but so your argument is if if we can
stand up to the welfare state
we can somehow get back to that world
the fam family structure will reassert
itself
that's gonna that that's gonna be
reconquering the same ground which is
really tough to do
but it can't it can be done
i was i was so lucky i at the time i had
no no clue about all this
as i was thinking earlier i'm like how
how can a 16 year old high school drop
out
go to college go to a prestigious
college like harvard
get a bachelor's get a master's and a
doctorate
but nowadays if you do that oh your life
is over
like high school dropout that you have
to like have some sort of
something to be able just to move on to
the next level education and it's like
it's mind-blowing as to
how not i won't say simple but how does
like
less complicated it was back in the day
to be able to
before
this implement implementation of welfare
came along and it's like
burn it down take it away i don't want
it anymore i mean i'm not benefiting
from it but
oh
like we actually
do most of the people you know that are
chronically in poverty is it because of
their choices or because of where they
were born
more
you have to pick one okay
more i know i know it's both i know both
definitely goes into it
i would say
more of their choices because yes they
were born into a
difficult situation
or a harder situation than normal
but their choices
have
landed them where they are now because
if they would have made different
choices they would be in a different
situation it's interesting i know rich i
know kids from rich families that are in
poverty because they just spend money
they don't have wow like i know like i i
have a
close relative that will always be broke
because he
does not know how to save money he's
always spending money he doesn't ha like
and sure he lives off my pa like he gets
some money from my parents for now but
at some point he's like after after a
certain age he's going to get cut he'll
he'll be broke forever
because he just doesn't
have any discipline or self-control
and you see it in his life because he's
very overweight he's very like it's
usually not just one thing i've noticed
like like some some not everyone
overeats right like they might be but
you just notice it's not like the lack
of discipline is just everywhere
it's a snowball effect one thing and
then it just
goes another